What approach is a window based [UNKNOWN]?
In this approach, a sender can only have
a certain number of packets outstanding or
quote, in flight. And the sender uses acknowledgement
from the receiver to clock the retransmission
of new data. So let's suppose that the
sender's window was four packets. At this point,
there are four packets outstanding in the network.
And the sender cannot send additional packets,
until it has received an acknowledgement from the
receiver. When it recieves an acknoweldgemnt on ACK
from the reciever. The sender, can then, send
another packet. So at this point there are
still four outstanding or four unacknowledged packets in
flight. In this case if a sender wants
to increase the rate at which it's sending,
it simply needs to increase the window size. So for example, if the sender wants
to send at a faster rate, it can increase the window size from four, to five.
A sender might increase it's rate anytime it sees an
acknowledgement from the receiver. In TCP every time a sender
receives an acknowledgement, it increases the window size. Upon a successful
receipt, we want the sender to increase its window
by one packet per round trip. So for example in this case, if the sender's
window was initially four packets, then at the end,of
a single round trip's worth of sending, we want the next
set of transmissions to allow five packets to be outstanding;
this is call Additive Increase. If a packet is not acknowledged, the window
size is reduced by half, this is
called Multiplicative Decrease. So TCP's congestion control
is called additive increase multiplicative decrease,
or AIMD. The other approach to adjusting
rates is an explicit rate-based congest control
album. In this case the sender monitors
the loss rate and uses a timer to modulate the transmission rate. Window based
congestion controal, or AIMD, is the common
way of performing congestion control in today's
computer networks. In the next lesson we will talk about the two goals of
TCP congestion control further, efficiency and fairness.
And explore how TCP achieves those goals.